now your solution may be a little bit
different than ours so let's take this
into account when walking through this
code now you'll notice that the full
range of Z indexes aren't actually used
inside of grids we allow for instance a
z-index value to be between 0 and 100
but in reality we only use about 10 or
11 of them but the values we do use are
actually scattered across the number
line you may have a bunch of them in the
range of 20 some of them in 50 and then
some of them in 90 the naive approach to
this solution would be to actually
create a simple for loop that would
represent and count through each of the
Z index values searching through the
array for any entity that has that value
in rendering it rather than wasting the
CPU cycles reiterating over the list
grits employs a bucket eyes method what
we do is if an entity is visible given
our view rec we'll actually go through
and place the entity in a bucket based
on its Z index value much like the hash
table we used before with the entity
class map so if we find that the Z index
for given entity already exists in our
array then we simply go ahead and add
that entity to our array if we find that
the Z index for intensity does not
already exist in our array then we go
ahead create a bucket for that Z index
so that future entities that has that
same value can be sorted appropriately
once that's done we go ahead and assign
this entity to its proper Z index bucket
afterwards we have a simple sorting
function that will sort the buckets by
their Z index value and then iterate
over the buckets drawing each entity in
turn